[Music]
this is my whole world my nurse my mom
my sickness I'm 18 and I've never been
outside if I did I would probably die hi
my mom sent a bunt welcome to the
neighborhood is your daughter around
no she you check in your emails
keep him out the window he's coming when
I talk to him I feel like I'm outside
she's here who's here you're really
different than I thought you were gonna
be sexier right what would happen if you
went outside probably spontaneous
combustion
here I have HEPA filters outside viruses
and bacteria why don't you go if you
could the ocean I've never seen it
you all have changed the way I feel you
sure you feel fine actually feel
perfectly I feel I'm standard steel is
it always like that it's never like that
it's not up to you to decide what she
need you have to go she was my friend
she was supposed to keep you safe you
can't see him again
chasing deer mom I know staying in this
house keeps me alive but this isn't
living
I want to experience everything
everything Maddy what are you doing go
back inside oh yeah I have to know if
I'm really sick the only way that I'll
know is if I'm outside
maddie was long I'm messing up your life
my life is better with you in it
mad love you all I have left I can't
lose you I'm willing to sacrifice
everything just to live one perfect day
it was 478 13 and the bill was 478 31
thank you you got the job at the circle
have a drink have a good time